thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a dynamic
wild ride with Stevo we've got Fred
Armisen this guy isn't just Dynamic he's
incredible he does it all music
acting comedy The Impressions my Lord at
the end of this episode is he going to
blow your mind with the Impressions he's
gonna take you all over South America
and it's just really remarkable he's uh
a fan of mine which is super epic he
loves jackass and he might have
destroyed Portland
um I'm not going to say he's responsible
for all of the terrible things that
happened in Portland but you're just
gonna have to judge that for yourself
it's juicy it's crazy this guy's
insanely talented and hilarious so
without further Ado let's get into it
okay so we're ready to Dive Right In all
right great okay
ladies and gentlemen Fred Armisen hi
hello yeah dude how's it going it's
going great thank you for joining us in
our humble van I was impressed with it
from the outside it looks really great
and I always wondered what hey
what happened to our son you know what
it was Green
that's all right I don't mind it like
that
oh there there we go maybe it's when you
shut the phone okay we were just saying
earlier that uh
uh we met
um in Vancouver I thought it was Seattle
for some reason but you're right it's
for just relax yep just for laughs you
had a show at the Vogue theater as did
Whitney Cummings and me yes we all
played the same theater I think we all
sold it out and we all had a blast yeah
uh because I think yeah that's how they
scheduled it for just for laughs yeah we
were just there for a while it was a
nice place too such a big deal for me to
have been embraced by Just for Laughs
you know like yeah I get not not a lot
of love from the entire comedy community
for having crossed over from my jackass
stuff into stand up
is that true I maybe I'm sensitive and I
perceive it more than anything yeah I
think it's a perception I think that uh
I'm sure that's not the case
I definitely care passionately about
putting on a great show yeah and um I'm
authentic in my approach to my comedy
and it meant a lot to be it just for
laughs to me I would say also I don't
think
I would say that I think jackasses isn't
something that's like uh separate from
stand-up comedy I feel like in general
in the community community not that you
need me to tell you this but uh I think
it's generally like a very accepted and
you know well thank you did you feel
that way when you went from music to
acting
um yes but I wasn't as huge as jackass
Jack is jackass is like a major part of
life you know yeah
yeah I mean when um when you got into
television and film it wasn't like oh
here look at this musicians over here
yeah no one was like no one was like oh
how come you're not gonna play drums you
know right yeah we just weren't
um we didn't have enough of an impact
for it to make a difference really yeah
did you bring your uh music
talents and and and performance into
Saturday Night Live yeah even in my
audition I had timbales you know like
the Tito Puente yeah those metal drums
um in my audition I had those and then
the first time I was on I had them and
for this character and then all the way
through
there there it's almost like I would
just work it into a sketch that I was
playing drums or guitar or something
it's almost like um like a crutch or
something and not like a crutch like in
a bad way like I didn't know what else
to do it's just that
that's just what
um came most easily to me did you have
to audition for Saturday Night Live oh
yeah in time did you do your your
impersonations was that yeah the main
one and then you incorporate that with
your drumming too yeah so it was like it
was like they asked me to do Impressions
and then some characters so I did that
at a club and they all show up and I do
it at this club so it was two
Impressions two characters and then I
did it again at you know at the studio
of SNL yeah and I that's the part I
couldn't believe was even happening for
me to even be in that room was insane
what Impressions did you do for the
audition I did Sam Waterston from Law
and Order and Vin Diesel
so Sam Larson is one that I'd been doing
anyway and then Vin Diesel was more like
I thought oh I should find think of
someone really famous so that at least
it you know I'm not doing it just anyone
to you know whatever or like it just
yeah I was going to ask you which Vin
Diesel did you do but he he's the same
in every movie he does he's like Keanu
Reeves like I did it just for the
audition I was like okay I'll try to
learn him and there's a thing he does
with his mouth you know there's this
kind of uh quality to the shape of his
skull or something that uh I thought I
think I can handle that so I just did it
quick enough that it didn't have to be
like you know am I clear that you're
attributing the way Vin Diesel speaks to
the shape of his skull yeah
I think there's a way that that it just
reverberates or something that
um you know yeah it's not a it's not a
put down I mean he's got a great skull
I think there's just something in there
like that you know sure did you walk out
of that audition thinking you killed it
I want I you know there's a sort of line
of auditioners just a few
um and someone called me back from the
staff of SNL like can I talk to you for
a minute and that I knew something was
up yeah I was like oh I think
something's starting to happen just
because she had some questions and
someone asking questions is a little bit
like
engaging so right I was like oh
something's about to happen and then
later that day they called me and and I
knew my life was going to change and
then it did it was I was like oh I think
my life's gonna be really different now
and then it did turn out that way that's
right that's when you have to you had a
landline you got to stay around your
landline all day it was it was 2002 and
I did have a cell phone but it was one
of those like uh Nokia ones and we
should mention Nokia yeah thank you
shout out to the snake you know the ones
that looked like almost like an egg yeah
a black egg with the bottom that's kind
of flat I don't think there's any
texting back then
you know I think I didn't know how to do
that yet or I wasn't like some people
were really good at that right
um so Saturday Night Live
um I I think of you more as the
Portlandia guy than Saturday life so
yeah which one do you think uh you're
most known for uh it depends where I go
but I in a way portlandian because it's
more of my signature yeah meaning like
it's more of sketch more sketch that was
like where me and Carrie are the main
people
um but you never know I mean sometimes
I'll you know I'll go to some place and
they'll just say SNL so it just depends
but Portlandia is more like focused
that's like a more focused way if
someone recognizes me that's more like
uh it's yours and it's it's more mine
yeah right is it true they try to blame
the like Rising real estate prices in
Portland to your show because everybody
wanted to move there and yeah I guess I
it's hard to tell you know because like
even if somebody said that I don't know
if that's how everybody thinks yeah but
uh
um because they had Billboards that said
you know home of Portlandia and things
were I'm sure people weren't excited to
see stuff like that I just people get I
suppose protective of where they live
yeah it um if someone made a show about
uh this part of LA
I guess you know yeah but um but I I
still don't know that like a TV show we
were a little cable show yeah can really
affect real estate I I don't think that
that's right we had that much power but
whatever you know the show's done in
Portland as a city has moved on so yeah
heroin and Method on the street it's
like yeah they blame you for that too
um it's funny that like how fast time
goes though like that you know the that
show would be in a discussion like that
and then years later it's just it's just
like a a newspaper page turning
um I went
I went and I worked on a movie there
uh I don't know maybe four years five
years ago or something and the girl who
was working was young was like you know
signing me in for whatever I guess for
covet tests so I guess it was like three
years ago
was like have you ever been to Portland
before
so in my ego I'm like okay I'm back you
know and then to her she's it's you know
that's how fast
I don't need to explain how fast time
goes but you know what I mean like sure
I don't know in your ego you're like to
the center of this like yeah of course
this thing and then for sure but in
regular life people are like we could
care less I she clearly had never didn't
even hear it hadn't even heard of the
show yeah you know yeah the uh it's
Portland that is the only place in
America that has decriminalized all
drugs right like is that true or do they
decriminalized heroin and Crystal Method
whoa deal like in that case study's not
doing very well right I think that
they've won like a decriminalize it if
not just legalized well I saw yesterday
that New York City was putting out
vending machines that had you can go and
get a a crack pipe you can go get like
tinfoil syringes and like that somebody
was posting that and it was pretty now
what do you think the reason behind that
is to like stop the crime rate
yeah like it's probably like that sort
of
Dutch you know ideology like we're just
going to decriminalize yeah everything
although I don't know what their laws
really are but I think there's that's
probably like a version of it we were
there uh at the beginning of this year
and it was just alarming it was truly
alarming just everywhere you looked
people were holding lighters under tin
foil and in broad daylight too not even
trying to hide is Portland you're saying
yeah that's the way it was when I was
there in the 90s I went through his when
I was in a band and people would say
like you know it's a kind of a druggy
Place sure enough exactly like you
described or just lighting like little
pipes and stuff right in front of um the
satiricon where we were playing yeah
what band was that that you were with
trench mouth yeah yeah very cool so yeah
I mean I it was a great City but it was
very that that's the main that was the
headline when we started yeah I wish it
was I mean I love Portland it's probably
like top three favorite cities minus all
the crime because it's such a beautiful
I love the weather I love the how all
the buildings are stacked up on the
river right there and yeah I still have
I have a place that I go all the time or
frequently but um it's there are parts
of it that are beautiful and also
I go to other cities and there's like
some La has some pretty messed up areas
sure yeah definitely oh you know not
just downtown I mean all over the place
and San Francisco obviously Hollywood's
Hollywood is pretty terrible crazy it's
intense yeah
Hollywood is like
I I drove down recently and there's
people who
are face down you're not even sure your
whole body
is like on the ground yeah with their
feet facing up like not just messed up
but just like flat out they had to
remove some of the porta potties in
Hollywood because people were just
constantly oding in there oh my God you
know yeah I I just don't know how that
works I don't have any answers I don't
know like I don't know and it's crazy
because like you hear you hear stories
of Hollywood in the 40s and 50s and it
was like clean everywhere and you're
like you're walking around where all the
stars on the the Hollywood Walk of Fame
are like that's where people used to
take for like a nice restaurant and like
go see a show and yeah it's like this
place where there's tents set up in the
late in the ladies pissing in Broad day
it's crazy yeah where do you live where
are you uh I live by Universal Studios
okay and so you get to see yeah but I
grew up in Pasadena and it like I mean
it's crazy because some places got
better some places got worse I remember
when I grew up like Highland Park was
like a No-No and you know property
values were like 80 90 000. and and now
it's they're 1.6 million dollar houses
and you're like man in high school like
the Bigfoot Lodge you couldn't go down
there so they called it a No-No they're
no they're just like be careful because
like you it's a rough neighborhood all
by Dodger Stadium the whole area and now
it's like getting gentrified and you see
people walking around it's so funny when
I grew up in New York I just interrupted
you you're about that yeah it's fine
you know I actually have a weird
satisfaction in being interrupted
because it's been so important to me to
improve my conversational
etiquette and not interrupt people let
them speak I think I've been getting a
lot better and that's very satisfying
but nowhere near as satisfying as taking
a very complete and healthy dump with my
Squatty Potty what makes it a complete
and healthy dump if you're pooping with
your feet on a Squatty Potty it's
because that raises up your knees it it
gets your body in a position which is
the same as squatting and that's how we
were intended as human beings to poop is
squatting we were not supposed to sit on
toilets that's not our DNA and when
we're squatting then all of our plumbing
is in the right position for a complete
evacuation that's why it's just plain
healthier to use a Squatty Potty and if
you go to squattypotty.com
Stevo you can get 20 off your order now
to be clear I've been using this product
as long as I've lived in this house
which is just about an entire decade so
I've been a loyal customer long before I
was in a business relationship with this
company I'm proud to represent them I
implore you to take healthier dumps so
one more time go to
squattypotty.com slash Devo to enjoy 20
off your order and much more satisfying
and complete dumps now let's get back to
it I was just gonna say I'll make this
really quick I thought even that
exciting but when I grew up in New York
on Long Island
same thing there was a No-No area which
was anywhere below Avenue a so they're
like you do not go below Avenue a you
were just where where what district is
that that's like Lower East Side so like
there's like the village and then as you
go you know there's like First Avenue as
the numbers get lower then it starts
going Avenue A Avenue B that was like
even saying I went to Avenue B was like
oh that was a war zone and that's like
uh in the 90s
80s 80s what was it like taking the the
subway in the 80s in New York was it it
was it was exciting it was it was
exciting because um you really felt like
oh I'm really in the city because it was
noisy like like something about it like
really felt like I'm not in the suburbs
anymore
you always feel like it's a TV show like
you know the gangs are walking on one
end and the other they're beating up the
fight or something like that no I didn't
see any of that yeah
um as a like punk rock musician I mean I
it just feels counter-intuitive that you
were this prolific punk rocker when you
seemed so soft smoke and mild-mannered
like what were you different in trench
mouth were you like a tough guy no
it's the kind of punk rock that I grew
up on
was the kind of soft-spoken punk rock so
like Hugh Cornwell of the stranglers or
Captain sensible
um
even Mick Jones even though they had you
know strong accents I felt like they
came up with sweet Melodies and were
like basically there's something sweet
about them and positive even Mark
mothers bought from Devo is kind of he's
kind of soft-spoken David Byrne
so I'll put in the punk category is like
a soft-spoken guy so
somewhere in there
I found like a voice of punk rock that
resonated with me you know who else I
think is very soft-spoken Perry Farrell
totally yeah absolutely yeah Bob mold
too like when he talks is just do we
consider Elvis Costello to be Punk yes I
do and and is he kind of yeah and he's
like brainy yeah he's brainy in in his
own way self-spoken that's that's always
a good discussion like who people
consider to be Punk but I
but then I try to do the evidence I try
to think well he produced the specials
he was like one of the first people you
know Elvis Costello the
be on American TV and stuff representing
Punk so I always think like that that's
that's definitely a punk yeah
um do you if you if I were to ask top
five Punk albums of all time
five Punk albums of all time I would go
Sandinista by The Clash
I would go dig Me Out by Sleater Kinney
I would say
um
new day Rising by who scored you
um then
I would say I Against I yes I was gonna
say that right thank you
yes I didn't want to sound dumb but I
was like can I get high against either
it was so amazed that you said that I
mean these Bad Brains eye against eye
Bad Brains might just be the
the greatest punk band
man like every time you see the Bad
Brains you're just like that's like
above everything else no matter how much
I love all these other bands
they're um I was gonna say number five
the Damned uh The Black Album but yeah
Bad Brains what
they don't they deserve like
a Nobel Peace Prize or something or they
they deserve
and something bigger than the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame someone's got to come
up to them like I can't I I wonder what
that was like for them to start like
right completely
just sort of isolated and just getting
into the scene
I don't know who would you say are your
top five albums
um
had a lot of um
influence with like the New York
straight edge hardcore oh yeah so uh you
know I'm gonna
like probably lean into the Gorilla
Biscuits a little bit there yeah
um you know that that first Gorilla
Biscuits it was an EP but they're great
yeah it's a big mouth and hold your
ground all that like that was a big deal
yeah
um yeah dude so uh yeah biscuits I think
like
they just recently got back together or
something or like they recently did
something they've done some Nostalgia
Gorilla Biscuits touring what is fugazi
they're way up there wait there they you
know they're just yeah
that uh was it the 13 songs album the
head waiting room on it yeah that that I
think that would make my top five you
did you open for fugazi yeah a bunch of
times how were those shows oh incredible
I mean and then also you learn about
like what bands are like as people so as
we got to know fugazi there's like a you
know not rock star way of doing things
nothing wrong with people acting like
rock stars that's fine but we liked as
an example of them not asking for too
much from the world they just wanted to
play a show and that was it they wanted
to play their music
and they weren't talking about you know
how they're going to do their next video
and who they're opening for it was just
a sort of they were they were happy
where they were and that's like a nice
thing to see they insisted on keeping
their ticket prices at no more than ten
dollars yeah really yeah well back then
it was five dollars they had five dollar
door prize and I'm sure yeah there's a
there's an interview with uh Nirvana
back in the day when they're you know
talking about how
um so you know some of these bands are
charging like 50 60 70 for concert
tickets and they're like who's charging
that they said Madonna Madonna yeah are
you kidding me I know they kept it at
like five ten dollars you know
so did you ever tour around with uh see
Nirvana In the Mix no no no we missed it
yeah we're sort of not in that scene
plus they were so huge it's so funny
that back then Madonna was like the
biggest like reference point of success
Madonna always just came off of that
would be like you know otherwise you're
gonna be like a Madonna all right you
know nothing against Madonna I'm just
saying that it was just funny that like
in the same way that we say like Taylor
Swift today yeah Swifty
yeah Madonna was like the reference
point of success you're acting like
Michael Jackson
uh yeah
I wonder I think you're younger than me
you must be I am I was born in 1974. oh
yeah you definitely are I'm born in
1966. yeah you said Gorilla Biscuits I
was like I see where you are
yeah you guys both spent some time in
Brazil growing up what
I spoke my first words in Portuguese in
Rio de Janeiro at six months old what's
the story
I was born in England
and my family moved to Rio when I was
six months then moved to Venezuela when
when I was two
uh Connecticut when I was four my dad
worked for American multinational
corporations what's the company that he
looked for at the time he uh worked for
Pepsi he was the president of Pepsi Cola
Brazil
that's incredible
um
my dad worked for IBM that's why we were
in Brazil that but for me it was like
second and third grade and my mom is
from Venezuela so we were there wow a
whole bunch of times
wow I spoke Spanish in Nursery School in
Caracas Venezuela so I think that you've
even been to Venezuela it blows my mind
and uh it's it's a it's sort of
embarrassing but funny fact that I
learned to speak three languages
fluently by the age of I think three and
forgot two of them completely by the age
of five
but that's so early that how can you
understood and while that it's it's uh
sad and depressing and and kind of
embarrassing but also they say that by
learning multiple languages
um you know when you're very very young
you develop more of your brain so even
though I lost those two languages
um I I arguably operate with more of my
brain than had I not learned them
definitely and what's even more
fascinating is that when I was in summer
camp at the age of I want to say 11
years old there were some kids who spoke
Portuguese at the summer camp and and
they they I woke up in the morning they
said dude like uh I mean they didn't say
dude but they were they were very
excited telling me that in my sleep I
was speaking Portuguese
I have no like I was in there somewhere
exactly I have no access to it but it's
in there and it came out in my sleep
that's pretty incredible yeah while
we've been to the same places
like you know years apart but in our
youth like yeah I don't remember that's
really early Brazil or Venezuela where
in Brazil were you Rio de Janeiro wow
and I went to an American school there
and they were Brazilians there too and
every time we spoke English the way
they'd make fun of us
is you know we'd be speaking in English
saying whatever and then these kids
would be like
that's how they make fun of our language
that's what it sounded like to them
that's funny that's great at what age
did you find out your dad was Korean and
not Japanese
oh recently like maybe five years ago or
something so your whole life you thought
you were half Japanese not half a
quarter my dad is a quarter my dad is
half German yeah and half what we
thought was Japanese and it turns out
that
my grandfather
had to fake his nationality when he
lived in Japan he's Korean but he
pretended to be Japanese because there
was so much racism against Japanese
people
that you changed his name and everything
that's so crazy to be indiscernible you
know to have everybody know way of
telling
apart but intense hatred yeah
it's uh that's like it's crazy that's
like how crazy it was in Rwanda
Yeah by what happened with Rwanda
they've had this like they split
everybody into these two groups but
there was nothing different between
these two groups what were they called
the two seasons
yeah there was it was just like some
crazy while you were there no we were
there in
2003 or four
2004 and um they were like just amputees
like it was it was gnarly they had like
a hundred days of
which is genocide and and for again for
no discernible difference between these
people and and the hatred crazy
how does it happen that's such a dumb
question but it's incredible that
they're like this close and then somehow
I mean I understand there's differences
in religion and stuff but I'm always
amazed especially with that
you know it makes it you know what more
than anything I feel ignorant I'm like I
have no idea how all right stuff starts
yeah I mean it stemmed from the the
Belgian occupancy of uh of the country
of Rwanda
they um you know when it actually came
to be it was a propaganda thing with
these like loudspeakers like uh blasting
you know on this day or this is gonna
happen and and it was just it's crazy
how people will
yeah can can be influenced to do such
such awful things it's funny that
they're never suspicious of loudspeakers
because loudspeakers they look so like
propaganda they look like propaganda oh
my God and then people still follow it
they just it just looks like trouble
some things look like trouble and some
things just are trouble like all the
plastic in the ocean destroying the
environment killing the wildlife it's
got to stop and you know who's stopping
it the good Folks at liquid death that's
right they put all of their healthy
beverages sparkling water Still Water
flavored sparkling water teas all of it
comes in infinitely recyclable aluminum
cans and did you know that like 70 of
all aluminum gets recycled like the the
success rate for for recycling aluminum
is phenomenal unlike plastic which is
destroying the world and I'm just in
love with this company they've got all
of their cans designed to look like
beers they love it when little kids get
in trouble with their t-shirts because
their teachers think they're drinking a
beer I mean everything about this
company all of their social media all of
their merchandise it's just punk rock as
hell and I love it they're trying to
save the world and I want you to join us
so if you want to get 20 off of your
first hilarious liquid death merchandise
item your first purchase 20 off for the
listeners of the Wild Ride podcast if
you go to liquiddeath.com
Stevo you can also get all the healthy
beverages on Amazon and from local
retailers get on board with liquid death
I love them I support them and I think
you should too so one more time
liquiddeath.com Stevo and let's get back
to it
I've watched the show I downloaded it on
iTunes it was uh came from a e was on
iTunes about the Jonestown Massacre that
was uh another example of loudspeakers
doing oh yeah terrible that's right
that's right instructing them all
what a mess oh my God also if you're in
a position of power and you have to use
loudspeakers you should question
yourself because I wonder if that guy if
Jim Jones was like had a microphone I
was like okay everyone you ha I would be
like wait a minute I became that
cult leader or whatever as soon as you
speak into a mic and it's loudspeakers I
think it's and so like he was just
loaded on drugs yeah yeah like just
slurring into the loudspeakers like he
killed himself too right yeah but it was
like
I think like maybe like a mass side and
slash murder like like 900 people
drinking
um
what do you call the the cyanide yeah
they put cyanide in this in this
knockoff Kool-Aid and
the people who drank the the Kool-Aid
there's nothing peaceful about this
cyanide death they were like screaming
in agony like uh and there's just all
this pressure to to do it and and having
witnessed how much Agony all these
people were in uh Jim Jones when it was
his time he shot himself he didn't drink
the Kool-Aid
that's what the whole documentary is
about oh my God it's so it's so heavy
and it was like people make jokes about
Kool-Aid and you know drink the Kool-Aid
yeah it is heaviest there's a lot so
many people and yeah is that where that
reference comes from drinks yeah don't
drink the Kool-Aid yeah drink the
Kool-Aid is like subscribe to the you
know the crazy like I thought it was
like the the Kool-Aid Grateful Dead tour
in the 70s
because that would be more like drinking
no you want a drink yeah you want to
drink that Jonestown one was just
deeply disturbing and super upsetting it
was not a mess I had it was way more of
a mass murder so what he had 900 people
drink the Kool-Aid at the same time yeah
and they started out with making the
kids do it whoa and then like and it was
just kind of understood that if you
didn't make the kids do it and drink it
yourself that you were just going to be
killed anyway so just because something
was coming for them right it was like
they're coming
you got to do this before something like
that yeah something was imminent Haley's
comment was coming no no no no that was
that was the legitimately funny one
which was Heaven's Gate
that was the one you bought merch for
yeah yeah I got done watching the
heavens game uh documentary series on
HBO it went right on Amazon bought
myself a Heaven's Gate t-shirt really
yeah because that one was like they're
all wearing the same sneakers they're
all where they're all like neatly made
up in the bed like it was much more
peaceful and and like genuinely a
suicide where people were just trying to
get on the rocket ship you know that's
incredible the spaceship came to bring
them to the to the special place how
often does it happen then like every
every 92 years no no no I mean like a
mass side with a cult leader oh I don't
I mean if you can't wake up and Jim
Jones and Heaven's gay I think that
those were pretty close to each other
and I don't know that we've had someone
since then no we haven't what decade was
that what were all those 94 was that 10
seconds was 70s
right I think it might have been
beginning of the 80s
and then Waco's 90s yeah Heaven's Gate
yeah I don't know I didn't have a new
one wait man we really we really went
there
we really went there
um I loved your uh uh stand up comedy
for drummers oh thanks on Netflix
I love that you uh got the the
well-deserved Grammy nomination for that
thanks thanks a lot yeah
I'm psyched I got to do it it was you
know targeted to musicians and drummers
and uh I I can't you know when I first
did it uh I didn't know what I was gonna
do so the more I did drumming jokes the
more like Drive I had to do it
uh and then all of a sudden I had a
special ready to go I think when I did
Vancouver that that show I think I was
doing some of it back then too I'm
pretty sure and what I particularly
loved about that was that you had these
vignettes
you know it was it was a multimedia
comedy special yeah and that's uh like
that that's what I do like with with my
stand-up you know like I filmed
vignettes like super crazy high level
jackass stuff that that crosses the line
of what would be allowed on jackass so
it's like my show is kind of a too hot
for Jackass like extra crazy you know
forbidden stuff that you're getting like
what would be something like having a
medical professionals administer stolen
general anesthesia drugs while I'm
riding a bicycle
no yeah oh yeah yeah you know what an
epidural is yeah becoming paralyzed
while sprinting
like uh my legs just got shaky thinking
about how yeah there's uh it's pretty
you know like pretty ambitious pretty
like you know scary dangerous stuff and
and um
and then I I that's my new tour it's
called The Bucket List tour it's not a
new tour anymore I'm getting ready to
tape the special and wrap it all up but
uh The Bucket List stunts get
um
you know they like built into a an act
where I tell the stories and and um it's
all set against the backdrop of my
relationship and how these things had
implications and uh you know at the end
of each bit I paid off by playing the
video of the bit so and when you go play
places what are the crowds like
um
I mean I think people uh it's it's sort
of a jackass kind of a kind of
demographic thing you know I mean I
think Jackass has been largely uh
defiant of demographics yeah so like
it's anybody like there's no physical
look yeah listen to someone who I find
that as I've become a multi-generational
guy that it's really alarming I feel
like uh Matthew McConaughey when he says
I get older they just stay the same age
yeah and I like it's like kind of
shocking how young my audience yeah is
and you know like so so yeah it ranges a
lot but I feel like that happened this
time around because everybody wanted to
bring their now those people have kids
and it's like I don't care how you know
my kid is I'm gonna take him to go see
jackass forever and then you have this
whole new influx of eight to 15 year
olds that are going with their parents
yeah yeah it's crazy that's amazing but
when you were uh touring with that job
yeah did you bring the vignettes with
you on tour yeah there'd be like a map
if I do accents from around the country
and stuff like that but I don't know if
you find this sometimes it's hard to get
Tech to work so if you have a projector
and a screen sometimes it's not
something goes wrong with it so I I rely
on it not too much but I do have like an
iPad to play music
and then once in a while on the screen
I'll have like
um a map of the states so so the video
of vignettes from uh yes uh once in a
while I'll have it like but I really
have to make sure that like okay do they
have a projector does it work can
someone work it just because I don't
have a like a big enough crew to have
one person yeah what made the difference
for us was a part of the tech writer and
part of the contracts it said like you
know you must have this you must have
this and if it doesn't work then you are
to refund everybody in the audience and
they will
have to be tested before we get there
and they do not want to refund everybody
in the audience you'll still get paid
but everybody gets their money back
uh I wish I did that because I think my
tone going in is always like hey
whatever you have great we want to make
this show and I think if you go in
saying this the AV has to work yeah it's
so funny we've never had we haven't had
did you say that I don't want to lean on
too much I'm like man my show is like
100 I wish that's all we lean on well
because that because that happened to us
in Colorado and it was just like how is
this happening and then it was like well
why did this happen and the guy had to
go you know they had to go buy a
computer at Walmart the next day and
that wasn't it was like uh when you say
this happening Carter this happened in
advance of the show and it was fixed by
the time the show happened no no you
remember in Colorado uh Denver when we
did that show and half of your skits
weren't working and you it was like we
were losing our mind and you're like
yeah I would love to play this but the
[__] video is not showing yeah I
remember I don't I don't remember there
ever being a show that uh it didn't end
up working yeah you probably you're so
pissed [__] blocked it out of your
brain like your Portuguese I mean it was
like
I remember that too because like it was
it was [__] atrocious and then it was
like okay wow it seems like we owe
people refund some days they got them
and it became a whole thing then they
got the refunds yeah oh there you go
yeah so so that's what happened okay
what do you fill it with I guess you
just keep talking and yeah and yeah
Steve was so pissed he's like and this
is the part of the show where the video
goes in
I would do more if I could that's an
interesting statement I would do more if
I could what if I could tell you that
you can do more
no problem and by do-more I mean be
better in bed now how do you do that
yeah you try Bluetooth tablets which
make you better in bed because they've
got the same active ingredient as both
Viagra and Cialis except they cost only
a fraction of the price and if you think
I'm kidding about do-more no no no no no
I'm not you ask my lady she loves it
when I chew a Bluetooth tablet and then
about a half an hour later
when we do our thing and when you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo man it's really easy to get your
prescription because they've got the
medical provider on the site you sort
that out and you can get an entire
month's supply of Bluetooth tablets
completely for free
all you pay is five bucks for shipping
so how about that it's time to do more
in the bedroom and do it for free just
pay five bucks for shipping for that
entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets completely for free at
bluetooth.com with the promo code Stevo
jump on that deal and let's get back to
it
yeah or I should because it's also I
think the audience likes it I think so I
think it's like instead of looking at
one person they get to see a video and
you can you know their mind can I think
that that it opens up so much and and
for me in particular
um it's like providing receipts you know
so many stand-ups yeah kind of tell
stories that are are made up or they're
just so ridiculously embellished yeah
yeah and in my case I tell stories that
are absolutely absurd just implausible
to the Max and then I play a video that
proves it all to be completely true oh
that's good that's good yeah I know that
it's like a common thing isn't it people
sort of exaggerate the story on stage
yeah and that's great I mean that's a
show business yeah that's what you're
supposed to do there's nothing yeah
there's nothing wrong with that it's
just it's just the beginning of
entertainment I'm sure
and um yeah and I just I love that you
did that with that special no I I loved
it plus I get a drum kit up there and a
guitar and stuff I think I like I think
I just like having drums around I like
the they look great it makes the stage
look for me like more full you know I
just like it how many instruments do you
play because I've seen you on guitar
I've seen you on drums guitar drums and
bass that's it
that that that that that's on Motley
Crue plays right yeah
that's the basic thing like I can do
like a chord on piano and make it sound
like a chord but do you make your own
music while you're at the house just
fake uh just uh parodies of other bands
okay for but I no serious music of my
own of like now it's my turn to like I I
I'm not good at that I'm good at making
fun of genres but that's it yeah when
you say parodies of other bands do you
ever go like full Weird Al
no not like that just because I think
he's got all the real estate in that but
it's more like uh for this show
documentary now we did a fake like
eagles kind of band like soft rock and
then like a fake Talking Heads band so
stuff that's like uh a concept you know
like uh that's for the documentary now
Series yeah and that that's current
right now yeah yeah
Yeah man so much fun where can people
watch that
IFC I guess it's like AMC Plus or
something does that have a uh there's so
that's the streamer as AMC plus yeah
it's been it's been I think Netflix has
it now but um uh we've been doing it for
like five years or six years or
something yeah that's you and Bill Hader
that's correct yeah and Seth Meyers
writes on a John molini writes on it
yeah so are you affected At All by the
writer strike can you because can you
explain to me what's going on with that
because I went to go drive to pick up my
laundry and everybody's striking but I
don't know what they're what what change
do they want to see
I think it's residuals for streaming
where I think
um
it's
pretty high I think for some uh
occupations and you know if you're on a
show yeah but I think the writers are
still on an older contract yeah okay
um and I used to you know sometimes I go
oh it's not affecting me I'm still doing
my thing but I think that's wrong it has
affected me and that sometimes I play on
Late Night with Seth Meyers
and the talk shows were the first to
shut down so it has affected me yeah
wasn't it wasn't able to work and so
sometimes because like I like to think
about working as not work you know like
oh I'm just getting to goof around my
friends but then I was like oh no no way
that's a real job that I have that I I'm
not working at Seth Meyers is fantastic
man he is the best
he's a great person brilliant writer
he's very fast
and he's Pleasant you know he's great
he's I am I loved his joke from his
special about
being
um a talk show host during the Trump
presidency he was saying that you know
it's kind of like being a Gravedigger
during the plague it's good for business
yeah
it works great but it's good for
business but you don't necessarily want
it to be happening yeah
[Laughter]
he's he's great he writes on the show as
well
yeah um man that's probably because of
the writers strike yeah I mean a
although I mean you know if I was
working I'd be
a lot of stuff shoots in LA but um
but yeah I mean that's because I'm not
in New York because of that right but so
we met you out in front of your office
what kind of stuff do you do during the
day in your office are you coming up
with new ideas are you constantly just
writing are you it's good for like um
Zoom meetings right like it's an
isolated place I have had writer
sessions there for stuff that uh me or
my production company is pitching and
then my drums are set up there so I I
could during the pandemic I would record
drums there for a Seth's show and so
and whenever I do my stand up I've got
all this music equipment so I just keep
it there so it's not at my house so I've
gotta like go through like gentle little
doors this is like right here it's like
a warehouse so I could load up a vehicle
with all that stuff how much uh are you
touring now with stand up
medium amount is that I did a tour
last year no this year
uh it was like a week or two and then
coming up I've got like one-offs like
Arkansas
Amherst Alaska I'm going up to play
there so it's like those you know sort
of like little Leap Frog when you go to
Arkansas are you gonna do your fantastic
Arkansas impression and like as opposed
to
like that's how you break down the
different yeah yeah parts of the South
uh I'm gonna try but I'm gonna like
brush up on it because if I do it as the
whole country it that's a little easier
because you know everything sounds so
different but if I go to Arkansas I
better get it right as far as like areas
of Arkansas yeah I think that I heard
you say that you could that you had
Arkansas like dialed in to the city
I say that when I'm if I'm on tour
you know for wherever I am I just did
some shows in Chicago and I was like
okay I'm gonna do all the areas of
Chicago but I brush up on it before I go
right so it's not like it's instantly in
my head it's more like let me just make
sure I have it right well it's like
Little Rock would just be Bill Clinton
right
that's where he's from
yeah but that's a uh his little his is
like a little more um upper class sort
of
Little Rock and then you got a point
like this
beforehand presidents were doing this
and it was like offensive and then they
stopped doing that and then they're like
doing this yeah and it looked weird so
that he found the middle ground and
that's why he was always that's good it
is gentle isn't it it's not pointing and
it's not like a fist yeah it's that's
why he's like no I did not sleep with
that lady I don't even know who that was
that's good though you did a good job of
it
so if you imagine being a politician you
got to figure out a new
thing to do with your hands imagine
being a politician and having to like
lie all day I feel like they just I feel
like they're so good at
answering questions I mean they must
take a class in order to they must
reflect to the the best degree you could
possibly can they must it must also be
there it's a probably a natural Talent
towards doing that of like avoiding
certain subjects and can you imagine how
polite you have to be all the time yeah
if you're a politician no matter who
comes up to you you got to be like yes
thank you oh I heard about that I'm so
sorry yeah it's like being a celebrity
and like somebody comes up and talks to
you at lunch and you're just like yeah
have a seat you're just like you know
all you want to do is [__] eat but if
you're a politician you can't say I just
want to eat no they work your sandwich
down and you work for them you work for
them and whenever they hand you like
macaroni you're like oh
you know yeah your your grandfather made
this wow
did you ever get a Donald Trump
impression going no and it's not in my
wheelhouse some people are so good at it
that I'm like I saw recently on uh the
stern Instagram they had uh
the these impersonator competitions
really good Donald Trump's going at each
other were they professional or like
underground like I don't know but it
would they were good enough it would be
hard for me to imagine that they were
not professional do you have one I do
not how do you know it's in your
wheelhouse I mean it's like because
you're good at other presidents and then
you're like you try to do Donald Trump
like nah I can't do that it just it
comes to you like uh
I was watching Joy Behar and I thought
oh I think I could do her it's like a
weird voice in your head that goes you
know where I go it just occurs to me
so Sam Waterston from Law and Order I
was watching him and I thought I think I
could do it that's how that's how that
all happens is just
my my brain nags at me when did uh it
occur to you that you could do Joy Behar
I was just watching her on The View one
day and I was just watching her I was
like oh I think I know people like that
very very New York
and yeah she she was always saying like
she's trying to you know brush stuff off
so she'd be like oh who cares I don't
know that's I don't know about that you
know and something about that I was like
oh and then I I just we just wrote it
into a sketch and it worked out I love
it are there impersonations you've been
working on recently
uh
to
I think they're too local but I've been
trying to do kai rizdal
you know he does like on NPR he does
like economics I'm not going to do it
because it's suit it's so like also now
that I'm gonna be on the spot okay but
that's just because I'm in my car and I
hear this he talks about economics and
I've been doing him
um but no not really yeah I feel like
when you're hanging out in your office
are you just doing impressions all day
by yourself when nobody's looking or
what are you talking in your head it's
like in my car I do yeah I think in my
car or from at the airport and I hear a
type of person it's like there's a way
that someone will talk
um
uh uh I just went to Germany and there's
like a just I don't you know I don't
know it just
it just occurs to me and I'll just do it
to myself yeah but I'm not on a sketch
show where I need to present it to
anybody I guess I could do it a stand up
yeah I feel like uh because I have such
bad OCD in my head where I feel like
that'd be a curse for me because I would
only talk like that person and I would
just be like shut the [__] up or you
think so if you went to like say if you
went to a hotel in Germany
and they said to you
um would you like two keys or one
you think you'd start talking that way
in my head and I would start doing it to
my friends and they'd be like what are
you doing people do kind of do that
though when they go to Europe all of a
sudden they start yeah talking like that
a little bit
so maybe I mean we went to Australia you
know we're talking like tell too easy
mate yeah I feel like it just becomes so
[__] easy as but I do that by myself
like sometimes I'll I'll watch a tick
tock video of somebody with Tourette's
I'm just like I [__] say the same
[__] they do by myself playing video
games at my house
I was like yeah it's just I don't know I
just got to be careful because I can go
down a [__] rabbit hole if I got
really good at an impression I would
just get into character all day I'm just
wondering about this Tourette's thing
there's a girl on Tick Tock named uh
Bailey and she's like yeah you ever seen
Ben and she's just like you know
feeding her dog her pen she's just like
[__] you [__] you and like I sent it to
uh to her buddy Paul and he's like dude
like you say the same [__] you know and
it's just like you just get so I don't
know I love it but I saw this video on
Reddit which was like a a group of
people with Tourette's got together
and just started talking and they were
making each other laugh so much because
they kept triggering you know they were
just they're making each other laugh
yeah because I could imagine if you had
Tourette's and you were in a group of
people with dreads that it would maybe
maybe get overwhelming and make you sad
well did you see that like oh you know
like we're all here like exhibiting this
thing that's that's
uh created problems for us you know and
maybe the compounding of that would yeah
yeah did you see that video this one was
that they were really laughing I love I
love that yeah there's a video of these
people that all had the funniest laughs
in the world they brought them all
together on a French talk show and they
just laughed the whole time because like
this person would be making a weird
noise and then yeah it would just set
everybody off I mean I love that kind of
stuff and you know when stuff seems fake
this did not seem fake I was like I
think they're really laughing yeah of
course oh God you guys really
I you guys really
did things not fake there are so many
fake yeah videos
and it drives me crazy I don't know how
they don't think that you can tell or I
can't tell you know like fake stunts
yeah you because you got approached by
some people in the beginning and you're
like I'm not faking [__] what are you
talking about yeah when I started my
YouTube channel I uh linked up with some
people who are very prolific and doing
prank videos on YouTube to kind of
launch my stuff everywhere kind of
coming up with what were we going to do
to collaborate together and and they
suggested oh we could just fake it and I
was like
I I have a really visceral reaction to
that I said if I ever fake anything and
then and by definition faking me if I
ever attempt to deceive the audience
yeah you know that's the where the line
is if I had to deceive the audience then
everything I have everything what's the
point then right exactly they can get
that anywhere right it's crazy it's
crazy how how far those guys went you
know yeah a lot of people
when uh when you get approached
to um
to be in a movie like Deuce Bigalow or
you know any of these Ron Burgundy yeah
yeah
um
like it is it
standard or
is it usual that they give you the ball
to just
yeah I would say that's usual let's say
they'll say this is the parameters for
how this scene is but you know obviously
go take it somewhere else or if you want
to do and
I love it and also when that happens I
try not to
prove that I can you know be funny and
like I want to do all these crazy I I do
try to keep it within
you know their working hours you know as
opposed to like making a scene into like
I don't know I don't want it to be like
where it doesn't make any sense anymore
so I I goof around but I try to keep it
um did I read that right that you're the
voice of Speedy Gonzalez on Looney Tunes
yeah on one one version of it
whoa which for uh like the cartoon in
the 90s no I would be the one from the
mid-2000s oh really yeah and so do they
give you parameter do they tell you to
go like that was more like these are the
Lions wow
um just because with animation you know
something as simple as that there's no
reason for me to like try to like
outsmart what they wrote right it's
Looney Tunes yeah yeah so exactly so but
with movies and stuff
Ron Burgundy was that way and
but yeah I'm always psyched if someone
asked me to do to be in something it's
the best especially when you have
creative license
yeah especially
because then I got to memorize too many
lions and I don't like memorizing too
and stuff
um you're friends with Lance bangs right
I am I love Lance Banks yeah I do too
yeah he's like a real
I've known him for a while I guess you
have too but I've worked with them for
many many years he's like a real uh
he's like cement of like different
groups of friends like he really is like
the center of like I just feel like
everybody knows him
in a really close way everyone's like
friends truly friends with him well he's
at the intersection of comedy and music
yeah and he's a fan
yeah
something about him though he's just
he makes things happen
like he did a was it his 50th birthday
party
um he just set up this birthday party
and like Mike Watt played all these
people Yeah Yeahs showed up and he just
died yeah and just at this movie theater
I don't know there's something there's
something in the way that like he when
he invites people
people show up if anybody listening is
not aware of plans oh I'm sorry I'm just
getting them we're actually shooting the
uh the um guy who's a cameraman on
jackass who's constantly barfing
he's barfing while filming he uh can't
stand the color red he's against him
what yeah like he said the one time they
made him film they painted a whole room
red and they're filming it
was he doing he's lost his mind freaked
out that's why the room that we filmed
the sweatsuit cocktail land was
completely wrong wearing red
oh really he's got like sort of wild
gray hair usually a beard a little bit
Jerry garcia-ish he has this and he's
getting he's he's getting he's pretty
quiet he's got like a quiet way about
him yeah we saw him during the pandemic
and he's wearing a mask and you know
exactly it's Lance Bank yeah you know
we've had him on Portlandia a bunch too
yeah we've done a bunch of sketches with
him
yeah we linked up with them last time
we're in Portland yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's crazy it's truly great
did he uh have anything to do with your
um drummer special he directed it there
you go there you go I didn't even mean
to I had to think about it for a second
I was like oh he had everything to do
with that special yeah he uh is a
prolific director of comedy specials and
music videos
yeah unbelievable his resume yeah yeah
my brother called me up he's like in
Austin he's like do you know Lance Banks
and like yeah how do you know him he's
like oh he's he's directing uh Jay
Larson's comedy special and then you
just see him pop up all over and he's
always got his hand in something he's
good he's really good he's somehow not
one of those people's like hey man tell
your friends about the right I'm a
director you know and let him know none
of that people just come here he
introduced me to this person zero he's
just
works and it's just you know yeah I
gotta ask you
um
you you did the voice for Red Dead yeah
I can't get in the red dead and
everybody loves it so much I I just
bought PS5 and the first one or the
second one the first two dead the second
Red Dead Redemption yeah you're not into
it it's it and maybe I'm doing this
wrong but I bought a PS5 because like
I'm just glued to my phone and I thought
this would be a good way for me to like
not look at my phone for an hour oh yeah
yeah you're gonna switch one screen yeah
my brain and I don't think about
anything and I love it and it's been
really really good for my mental health
and I know it's counterintuitive because
people say that video games are not but
this has been like a really great
experience
I've been playing I played doom and then
I went straight to Red Dead and it's
just such a slow storyline yeah that
like I can't handle moving that slow
during it I hear you that's the only
problem with it do you hook it up to
like a big screen that you can watch it
yeah
I mean it does take a lot of patience I
see what you mean because sometimes
you're on a horse you're like it's
cinematic it's beautiful and it's real
but I know what you mean I love it but
sometimes you're going up the mountain
on a horse and I'm in the snow in the
snow and I'm like I gotta feed the horse
yeah and I understand but I'm like you
gotta give me a break
you know like I should be able to just
go up the mountain fast fast and are you
able to like are you like shooting
people from the horse there's a bunch of
that there's and it's intermittent it's
intermittent but it's not like Call of
Duty where it's like it's [__] on or
it's not like Doom where you're like
this is you're walking up the thing and
it's like your buddy's yelling like I
gotta go back and get my [__] buddy
and it's like just and it's real
distances and you got to look on the map
and you're like there's no fast way to
get anywhere so you're like all right
I'm gonna go down through the valley and
like okay good I'm not the only one no
but I love it
but now that you're saying it I'm that
is the parts where I get quietly
frustrated because there are some people
I was looking up a twitch and there's
like a lot of people that do red dead
yeah and it's like a it's a great game
but it's just I I I'm new to video games
so I'm wondering if there's great
characters in it I mean I like that it's
like calm and you can just sort of enjoy
doing small things in that game
so and I like the challenges are pretty
good they're pretty interesting yeah you
can like die of tuberculosis or yeah
your chick cheats on you yeah and
there's like all sorts of things to
collect uh-huh you got to go to the shop
and stuff I know what it is I had to go
up a mountain
and the game told me that my jacket
wasn't big enough I've got to go buy it
so yeah go buy uh yeah to be warmer and
I'm like I'm into the game but don't
make me
go back into town go back yeah yeah
anyway I just wanted to I was reading
about the dad and I was like oh you do
the voicing for it yeah I I originally
worked with someone on Grand Theft Auto
and the reason I did it is because David
Cross did
um Grand Theft Auto uh and I got very
like I want to do that how did he get to
do that
so I kind of bugged them a little bit
until they got me on and there's this
guy Laszlo
who got me on that and then the first
Red Dead Redemption and then this one
for real the second one and you do you
love doing video games yeah what voice
over work do you love doing the most do
you love like the cartoon big mouth is
fun to do uh but do you like doing video
games better than cartoons or oh
I like video games better because it's
so uh unknown like there's a route if
you do an animated thing there's like a
way to do it and you know
video games are just so so much more
mysterious they don't really need you to
be a comedian or
so I like that I like that it's a little
I don't know something about it is like
more unknown that's cool yeah
um how much Spanish language stuff do
you do
a pretty good amount I did a lot of
spookies and uh I I try to do a lot
sometimes
I think that my Spanish is really great
and then when I really talk to people
who really speak Spanish
I I realize I'm just like on the
precipice of it like I still have to
slow down a little bit but I try to do
as much as I can do you have a um
Spanish impressions
um
no I one time Speedy Gonzalez Speedy
Gonzalez I guess
they know they sped that up a little bit
too oh really let me speak faster wow
Spanish Impressions no I should have
been prepared and come up with it I mean
I'm not trying to make you do a Spanish
Impressions yes or no um yeah no I guess
the answer is no
uh I mean I try to do different accents
from
uh different parts of South America and
stuff yeah uh Venezuela haki
uh
um
uh Argentina oh that's too hard for me
because they have that proper Spanish
it's a weird it's weirder than that is
yeah it's almost like that uh that dance
where you kick
what tank Tango is it El Paso doble or
that yeah I think that's it that's a
tough thing
they're very like expressive man that's
impressive
I love them that we made it over an hour
in before before
I love it I'm gonna tell people I'm
gonna say hey you guys stick around to
the very end yeah
that's really cool man I I love I love
that dude oh thanks I'm honored and and
uh and moved by that thanks you've been
to South America you know yeah yeah I've
traveled a lot and I'm just impressions
of are not my thing man I've never
I bet if you were in a jam and you had
to do an impression you'd be able to do
it don't clowns do impressions of like
what like didn't they tell you to act
like somebody when you're trying to be
maybe maybe I'll try and get myself into
a jam and and do it we'll put that on
our to-do list yeah yeah cool man
um so so let's uh let's let people know
what you're up to now
do we have uh do we have any tour dates
yeah when does this come out I uh August
6th I'm in Fayetteville Arkansas I think
a couple days later I'm in Amherst then
Alaska like a Anchorage for a couple
days
um and then just all over like I just
book stuff and I'll just where can they
go buy tickets uh I have no idea
just Google you it just works out and
people show up and it's been great you
know that that that's great man yeah and
there's a show called this fool that's
coming out soon uh which is about some
of the
um sort of Mexican-American community in
Los Angeles I'm not in it but I'm a
producer on it so that's coming out in
July
that's epic and and how many active
shows do you have is is losing spookies
active right now no no that's done okay
but this will be the only one that's
active right now okay and documentary
now I suppose maybe yeah I don't know
it's weird talking about stuff because
sometimes when I see people talking
about their own projects I'm okay with
it I'm like oh yeah they're just
promoting it but every time I do it I'm
like oh God does anyone want to hear me
I think it's I think it's uh it's
impressive and fascinating how many
different shows you've been a part of oh
thanks yeah
that's part of the problem is you got so
many goddamn things going on that you're
just you know Never Enough Never Enough
never yeah I always just want to keep
you know making something else are you
active on social media
ish I'm on Instagram but like I post
once in a while just for like shows or
tour dates and stuff like that but I'm
not
I don't know why some people are so good
at it I know man I I go through phases
that's what it's like for me
and then sometimes if a company wants to
promote something there's so much
they're like make sure to say this and
and also and then I feel like I'm
working and like this now this feels
like a job you know I was really good at
it is Tony Hawk he's just casual muscle
memory and and it's organic and and fun
and he's got such uh
unbelievable wealth of just archival
stuff that goes back decades and he's
always just mining some nugget of gold
and people do it I don't know I don't
know I guess on post yesterday where he
did a flip holding a glass of milk on
the half pipe yeah that was an older one
that was another one TMZ picked up yeah
pretty cool that's so
it's tough because how does he go
through his phone I would be like okay
where did I keep that right oh there it
is is it too long I don't know
but he's got but you're good at that
with the month and the year you can ask
him any situation and you'll be like
that was August of 94. like he's really
good at that I don't know except for
wild boys wild boys all Blends together
but yeah man I I think it's fantastic
and uh I think you're fantastic I'm
always happy for uh your guys you and
your you guys a success well I
appreciate that so let's do the test of
time it's crazy to think
multi-generational and still it still
works
like the tone of it everything what what
thank you man it's been an honor to have
you and uh continued success thank you
I'll continue to success to you yeah
dude
um did I yeah I always sing this to
everybody if there's anything that
you're not comfortable with just
legitimate nothing sent off any alarms
and uh yeah I think that's great man
yeah
Fred Armisen ladies and gentlemen is he
the most likable dude so talented and I
really think that uh the the thumbnail
for this episode is uh particularly epic
I don't know man
um some of you might have noticed that
uh again we did two episodes in one week
I mean what can I say we're in love with
delivering you guys content I think we
might do this for one more week
two episodes per week just as an
experiment to see how it goes but then
it'll probably be back to one per week
now you guys I love you so much for
supporting the podcast and I mean that
more than ever thank you for sticking
around to the very end and let us know
what you think man like we really do
watch the comments closely we really
care about the feedback now I'm kind of
scared of watching the comments
everybody else reports to me about them
ah but hey man I love you guys thank you
for the support and have a wonderful day